à Monsieur Olivier Hénault pour une mise
au point au sujet d'un vote oui merci
monsieur le Président je souhaite
apporter une rectification de vote pour
mon collègue Bernard Delcros concernant
le scrutin 113 de la séance du 31
janvier 2023 portant sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi relatif au Jeux Olympiques
et olympique de 2024 et Monsieur delcroz
souhaitait voter pour ce scrutin je vous
remercie
acte tes données de votre mise au point
elle sera publiée au Journal officiel et
figurant dans l'analyse politique du
scrutin concerné
l'ordre du jour appelle la désignation
des 21 membres de la mission
d'information sur le thème gestion
durable de l'eau l'urgence d'agir pour
nos usages nos territoires et notre
environnement et des 23 membres de la
mission d'information sur le thème le
bâtisse scolaire à l'épreuve de la
transition écologique en application de
l'article 8 du règlement les listes des
candidats remises par les groupes
politiques ont été publiés ces
candidatures seront ratifiées si la
présidence ne reçoit pas d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre règlement l'ordre du jour appelle
également la désignation des 37 membres
de la Commission spéciale sur la
proposition de loi visant à renforcer la
prévention et la lutte contre
l'intensification et l'extension du
risque incendie et des 37 membres de la
Commission spéciale sur la proposition
de loi visant à faciliter la mise en
oeuvre des objectifs de 0
artificialisation nette au cœur des
territoires en application de l'article
8 bis aligné à 3 de notre règlement les
listes des candidats présentés par les
groupes ont été publiés ces candidatures
seront ratifiées si la présidence ne
reçoit pas disposition dans le délai
d'une heure prévue par notre règlement
j'informe le Sénat qu'une candidature
pour siéger au sein de la mission
d'information sur le développement d'une
filière de biocarburant carburant
synthétique durable et hydrogène vert a
été publié cette candidature sera
ratifiée si la présidence ne reçoit pas
d'opposition dans le délai d'une heure
prévue par notre règlement l'ordre du
jour appelle la discussion de la
proposition de la relative à
l'instauration d'un nombre minimum de
soignants par patience hospitalisé
présenté par Monsieur Bernard Chaumier
plusieurs de ses collègues demande du
groupe socialiste écologiste et
République dans la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Bernard Jomy
auteur de la proposition de loi pour 10
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
madame la rapporteur mes chers collègues
c'était mi-janvier il y a 15 jours dans
l'État de New York les infirmières ont
déclenché un mouvement qui fut massif et
en quelques jours elles ont obtenu gain
de cause elles ont obtenu des ratios de
soignants par patience car il n'y a pas
que la France qui soumise à des
contraintes budgétaires a voulu résoudre
celle-ci en réduisant le nombre de
soignants au lit des malades dans ses
hôpitaux couplé à la stagnation des
rémunérations stagnation qui les années
passant s'est transformé en baisse cette
ligne politique a eu pour objet de
contenir le budget des hôpitaux en
actionnant la contrainte du premier
poste de dépenses la masse salariale
l'effet fut le même partout les
soignants mal payés et surchargés ont
commencé à quitter l'hôpital
alors si nous voulons rendre à l'hôpital
public son attractivité nous devons
répondre à deux problématiques
principales celle des rémunérations
incluant le travail de nuit et de
week-end et celle de la charge de
travail élément fondamental de la
qualité de vie au travail de la qualité
et de la sécurité des soins pour les
malades
le Ségur a apporté des réponses à la
première question et d'ailleurs il devra
encore être complété car trop
d'insuffisance et trop d'injustice
subsistent encore mais la question des
rémunérations ne peut-elle seule
maintenir ou ramener à l'hôpital des
soignants fatigués lacets de la
dégradation des conditions d'exercice de
leur mission
ces soignants nous les avons longuement
écoutés lors de notre commission
d'enquête sur l'hôpital rapporté par
Catherine de roche nous avons entendu
leurs colères face à la perte de sens de
leur métier leur métier il l'aime leur
travail est si consacre mais encore
faut-il qu'ils ne rendent pas chez eux
le soir en ayant parfois le sentiment
d'avoir été maltraitant par manque de
temps ce temps si précieux si l'on ne
veut pas résumer le soin à des actes
techniques mais respectez en lui les
dimensions relationnelles et humaines
l'unanimité de ce compte de ce constat
était frappante et nous nous devons y
apporter une réponse et l'unanimité de
ce constat nous devons d'autant plus la
considérer que nous pouvons en
identifier la source c'est un nombre de
soignants par patient qui a été réduit
au fil des années
il faut inverser cette évolution qui
s'appelait fondements des métiers du
soin en portant atteinte à leur valeur
il faut revenir à un nombre de soignants
par patient plus élevé à l'étranger
beaucoup de pays ont établi des ratios
souvent de 6 à 10 patients par un
infirmiers par exemple avec comme
résultat démontré une amélioration de la
qualité des soins moins de complications
des hospitalisations plus courtes moins
d'infections nosocomiales et d'erreurs
médicamenteuses un effet positif en
termes de dépenses et même relevé à
moyen terme car l'augmentation des
effectifs est plus que compensée par des
coûts évités sur les complications sur
les durées d'hospitalisation
et en France les ratios existent déjà
ils ne sont réglementaires que pour
certaines activités de soins mais ils
sont en fait dans la réalité ils sont
dans le quotidien
omniprésents les budgets de tous les
hôpitaux les budgets de restructuration
de tous les hôpitaux intègrent des
ratios de 12 à 15 patients par
infirmières quand la moyenne des pays
comparables est plutôt entre 6 et 10 et
en réalité oui tout le monde est dicte
des ratios mais le législateur lui
devrait rester silencieux quand ceux-ci
sont devenus un puissant facteur de
démotivation des soignants car fondé sur
des critères financiers car déconnectés
de la qualité des soins
les travaux préparatoires à notre
délibération et en particulier les
nombreuses auditions menées par la
rapporteur Laurence Rossignol dont je
salue l'important travail et que je
remercie ont révélé une unanimité des
organisations professionnelles et des
syndicats de soignants des infirmières
au kiné des sages-femmes aux médecins
tous demandant l'adoption de ce
dispositif et il le présente même
souvent comme indispensable pour stopper
le départ des soignants de l'hôpital je
veux croire que notre assemblée sera
répondre à cette demande et d'autant
plus largement que le texte adopté par
la commission des affaires sociales à
intégrer les remarques constructives
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs sur la
nécessaire progressivité des ratios et
sur leur adaptation aux spécificités des
établissements et des spécialités
Carl Popper en son temps à théoriser la
nécessité que nous affrontons
aujourd'hui d'une formule il faut une
règle du jeu et il faut du jeu dans la
règle nous ne devons adopter abandonné
pardon aucun des termes de cette juste
position la souplesse oui le renoncement
non aucun motif technocratique ne peut
justifier le refus de ratio conforme aux
enjeux de qualité et de sécurité des
soins quand ceux qui les refusent
appliquent sans état d'âme des ratios
financiers insupportables pour les
soignants
mes chers collègues aujourd'hui des lits
beaucoup de lits sont fermés faute de
soignants une enquête de l'agence pour
l'emploi des soignants menés en 2022
auprès des intérimaires montrent que les
critères principaux amenant à la
décision de quitter l'hôpital et qui
pourrait amener à y retourner ne
concerne pas la rémunération mais
l'adaptation des plannings est un ratio
infirmier par patient cohérent
dans son rapport du 17 novembre 2022
tout récent sur les déterminants de la
qualité de la sécurité des soins en
établissement de santé le collège de la
Haute Autorité de Santé confirme que le
lien entre les ratios de personnels la
qualité et la sécurité des soins était
payée par la littérature
alors mes chers collègues je sais
l'engagement de chacun et de chacune
dans notre assemblée pour que nos
hôpitaux de proximité nos centres
hospitaliers nos centres hospitaliers
universitaires ceux de nos territoires
retrouvent leur attaque activité et
répondre au mieux aux besoins de santé
de nos populations
la mesure que je vous propose
aujourd'hui que la commission des
affaires sociales vous propose
aujourd'hui est un élément de réponse
fondamentale attendue par les soignants
le Sénat en adoptant ce texte on verra
deux signaux majeurs
le premier signal aux soignants pour
leur dire que nous les avons écouté et
entendu et que nous prenons nos
responsabilités pour que le sens de leur
métier soit respecté pour que qualité et
sécurité des soins soit la règle et le
second signal au gouvernement auquel
nous demandons de fonder ses décisions à
venir sur une véritable approche de
santé non pas enyant la nécessité de
choix budgétaire mais en posant la
qualité et la sécurité des soins en
déterminant de ses choix leur n’est plus
aux paroles mais aux actes nous pouvons
nous devons prendre soin de nos hôpitaux
et de leur soignants je vous appelle à
adopter cette proposition de loi je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant à la présidente Laurence
Rossignol rapporteur de la commission
des affaires sociales pour 10 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur l'auteur
mes chers collègues voilà plusieurs
années que dans cette émission nous
discutons de la situation de l'hôpital
il ne s'agit pas une révélation qu'on
aurait eu Sénat à l'occasion de la
pandémie du covid-19 notre commission
aux affaires sociales se rappelle
particulièrement de l'automne 2019 et
des discussions pour le moins heurté sur
le PLFSS 2020 sur fond de grève des
urgences et d'annonces présidentielles
inopinées cependant malgré la tension
continue portée par les sénateurs à la
situation de l'hôpital malgré une
commission d'enquête au travail fouillé
et aux recommandations adoptées à la
case unanimité l'action du gouvernement
au service du redressement de l'hôpital
peine à trouver l'élan nécessaire et
j'espère que tout le monde aura apprécié
le féminisme
quelle est la réalité de l'hôpital
aujourd'hui dans la crise générale que
traverse notre système de santé les
soignants sont épuisés épuisés de ne
plus pouvoir exercer leur métier dans
des conditions décentes épuiser de
devoir assurer des gardes de nuit et de
week-end plus nombreuses faute
d'effectif en nombre suffisant épuisé de
voir les équipes se déniter constatant
les départs de ceux qui renoncent et les
remplacements intérimaires qui
fragilisent encore plus les services le
Ségur bien que nécessaire n'a pas
répondu à l'ensemble des enjeux
l'hôpital est fragilisé les équipes au
bord de la rupture et l'activité n'a
toujours pas en 2022 repris à des
niveaux comparables avant la pandémie
le rapport de la commission d'enquête
sur l’hôpital celui que nous avons fait
était titré sortir des urgences là est
bien l'enjeu principal auquel nous
devons toujours répondre dans les
services cela veut dire redonner du
temps aux soignants et avec eux redonner
du temps aux soins la rapporteur
Catherine de roche notre présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales
appelé alors à établir des standards
capacitaires qui accompagnait de
recrutement adéquat devait assurer les
équipes soignantes d'être en nombre
suffisant à la charge de soins et ainsi
retrouver des conditions d'exercices
convenables c'est cette recommandation
que Bernard Chaumier qui présidait la
fameuse commission d'enquête a entendu
traduire par la proposition de loi dont
nous des bâtons aujourd'hui son principe
est simple établir un nombre minimal de
soignants par patient hospitalisé
certains diront standard parfois
référentiels le mot ratio a finalement
été retenu la commission des affaires
sociales a et je m'en réjouis souscrit
au dispositif proposé
amender à mon initiative l'intention est
claire la Commission entend s'adresser
aux soignants et leur garantir une
restauration de leurs qualités de vie au
travail et de leurs conditions
d'exercice ces ratios sont-ils de bons
moyens pour y parvenir nous avons de
bonnes raisons d'y penser sont-ils le
seul moyen nous ne le prétendons
nullement en effet les expériences
étrangères confirment que c'est un bon
moyen et je pense particulièrement
Bernard jaumier a évoqué à la Californie
au Queen en Australie suffisamment
documentée montrant des effets positifs
très clairs liés à la mise en oeuvre de
ratio de soignants amélioration la durée
moyenne de ces jours baisse de la
mortalité ou encore des réadmissions les
rations ont des résultats favorables en
matière de santé publique ce n'est pas
une surprise la Haute Autorité de Santé
constatait d'ailleurs en décembre encore
une corrélation reconnue par la
littérature entre l'effectif médical et
les pronostics des patients
parallèlement les ratios jouent de
manière tout aussi clair sur la qualité
de vie au travail des personnels
soignants augmentation d'attractivité
baisse des situations d'épuisement burn
out soit précisément ce à quoi nous
voulons œuvrer pour la commission
rétablir l'attractivité et offrir des
conditions descentes d'exercice au
soignants sont des conditions
nécessaires pour reconstituer les
effectifs et renforcer les équipes ce
sont les moyens indispensables pour
faire revenir les soignants qui ont
quitté l'hôpital tout autant que pour
prévenir de nouveaux départs
madame monsieur le ministre c'est-à-dire
le ministre de la santé et de la
prévention avait déclaré qu'il ne
fallait pas non je ne m'adresse pas à
madame je cite monsieur ministre
excusez-moi il avait déclaré avait été
non pas à voz avaient déclaré qu'il ne
fallait pas sur ce sujet de mesures ni
brutales ni uniforme le texte issu des
travaux de la commission n'est ni
brutale ni uniforme et je ne doute pas
que vous serez le reconnaître pas une
mesure uniforme d'une part car les rats
de qualité que la proposition doit vivre
à créer distinguerait bien entre les
différentes activités et les spécialités
hospitalières pas question pour nous de
fixer une jauge aveugle et unique entre
la pédiatrie et la cardiologie par
exemple nous souhaitons que les ratios
répondent aux besoins différenciés et le
texte le dit à l'évaluation de la charge
en soins
pour certains ces ratio sont complexes à
définir et il est préférable de
travailler sur la prise en compte de la
charge en soins au quotidien service par
service dans les auditions j'ai beaucoup
entendu parler de la magie de la charge
en soins mais pourquoi cela n'a-t-il
jamais été fait voilà 30 ans que le
sujet est soulevé et on peine encore à
se doter en mesure de répondre à ce
besoin d'évaluation sans être une charge
supplémentaire grâce à la proposition
droit il deviendront une priorité et les
outils nous serons définis pas uniformes
je disais car nous sommes allés plus
loin en commission en prévoyant
également des distinctions selon la
spécialisation ou la taille de
l'établissement là encore la situation
différente traitement différent un
service de Chu avec des sources
spécialités n'a pas les mêmes besoins
qu'un CHR avec des unités traitant des
patients en moyenne moins complexes pas
uniforme non plus car attaché à
respecter le rôle des soignants de
terrain la Commission a bien prévu
qu'une fois ces ratio établi les
commissions médicales et de soins
infirmiers devraient s'en saisir le
texte prévoit qu'elles approuvent
l'organisation de soins dans
l'établissement au regard des ratios
fixés nous prenons en compte les
situations particulières et nous
laissons aux soignants la latitude
nécessaire dans la définition de leur
maquettes organisationnelles pas brutale
non plus car j'ai bien précisé en
commission et dans mon rapport que les
rations ne doivent pas s'entendre comme
des coups près mais bien comme ce que
nous appelons des fourchettes même si le
mot n'est pas indiqué dans le texte
l'intention y est et je ne doute pas
qu'on recherche toujours l'intention des
législateurs dans nos travaux la
Commission a également ménagée une autre
en vigueur progressive du dispositif les
ratios ne s'appliqueront pas dès le
premier juillet 2023 bien entendu on
sait que ce n'est pas possible on peut
pas nous soupçonner d'être aussi
responsable personne n'y croirait et le
prétendent serait au mieux un vœu pieux
au pire un danger la Commission à
veiller à la crédibilité du dispositif
est prévue que la mission de référentiel
donnait à la Haute Autorité de santé un
effet au plus tard au 31 décembre 2024
après quoi s'engagera un délai de deux
ans pour laisser au gouvernement le
temps d'établir les rats de référence
fixés par voie réglementaires cette
progressivité tient à la nécessité
d'évaluer finement les besoins mais
aussi et surtout d'engager de manière
réaliste des recrutements nécessaires
la Commission a en responsabilité
souligné à la distinction entre les
ratios de sécurité qui existent déjà
aujourd'hui et les nouveaux ratios
établis en vue de garantir la qualité
des soins et des conditions d'exercice
des soignants les ratios qui existent
aujourd'hui au nom de la sécurité des
patients sont prévus par décret et
constituent des conditions requises pour
le fonctionnement faute de quoi la
capacité d'accueil d'accueil restreinte
il concerne la néonatologie de la
rémunération nonatale le traitement des
grands brûlés la réanimation les soins
intensifs et l'insuffisance fraisale
très mal chronique les secteurs de
naissance et le traitement du cancer ont
également des exigences du même ordre un
ratio différents conséquences
différentes les ratio de pas ipso facto
de fermeture de lit le fonctionnement
des services sera assuré pendant une
durée donnée mais l'agence régionale de
santé sera informée d'état des effectifs
les ratiaux de qualité sont là pour
rétablir les capacités hospitalières par
la confiance et par les effectifs les
fermetures de lit c'est la situation de
l'hôpital aujourd'hui c'est pas celle
qui pourrait être advenir si notre
proposition de loi était adoptée c'est
ce que vit l'hôpital aujourd'hui vous le
constatez madame la ministre mes chers
collègues il n'est donc point question
de rigidité c'est un changement
d'approche qui est proposé sortir des
ratio de performance qui ont fragilisé
l'hôpital pour bâtir des ratios de
qualité pour finir je tiens à souligner
qu'évidemment la commission des affaires
sociales n'oublie pas la nécessité de
travailler sur d'autres enjeux
directement liés à l'attractivité des
métiers et aux conditions de travail et
qui concerne particulièrement le
recrutement
faut-il évoquer l'examen de motivation
supprimée dans parcoursup beaucoup des
soignants que nous avons entendu dans la
préparation de ce texte ont évoqué des
difficultés et des dysfonctionnements
dans les recrutement aujourd'hui en IFSI
ils ont aussi regretté que la formation
que la maquette ils ont voté la une
maquette où les qui qui
fragilisent également les conditions de
formation et encore autre sujet abordés
qui concerne les recrutements à
l'hôpital la question de l'accès au
logement dans les grandes métropoles la
commission croit la nécessité de ce
dispositif a entendu le message des
soignants médecins sage-femme infirmier
paramédicaux tous sont unanimes si la
Commission a souscrit à la proposition
de droit qu'elle vous invite à adopter
aujourd'hui elle l'a fait en
responsabilité convaincu que ce texte
n'est certes qu'une première étape une
brique mais que celle-ci est
indispensable s'engage alors avec cette
proposition de loi ce que j'ai qualifié
d'une noix de programmation
c'est à dire une loi qui voit plus loin
et qui doit déterminer les moyens à
venir j'espère que notre assemblée
adoptera ce texte à la large majorité
qu'il mérite et je souhaite que
l'Assemblée nationale et le gouvernement
pour substance ensuite le travail
sérieux que nous avons engagé au Sénat
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
maintenant Madame Agnès Firmin le Baudot
ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente de commission madame la
rapporteur monsieur le sénateur geomier
l'auteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est sur un objectif partagé
par le gouvernement et l'ensemble des
banques que nous débattons aujourd'hui
en effet face au tension auxquelles sont
confrontées certains de nos services
hospitaliers en tant que responsable
politique nous partageons un même sens
du devoir ce devoir est je reprends ici
précisément l'exposé des motifs du texte
proposé par le sénateur jaumier que je
remercie d'avoir d'ouvrir ce débat
d'offrir un cadre de travail décent et
bien traitant aux professionnels de
santé et de permettre une prise en
charge des patients conformes aux
exigences de qualité et de sécurité des
soins
la proposition de loi dont nous
débattons propose d'instituer pour
chaque spécialité éthique d'activités de
soins un ratio minimal de soignants par
lit plus précisément de fixer et de
faire établir au plan national par la
Haute Autorité de Santé un nombre
minimal obligatoire d'infirmiers et
d'aide-soignants de jours et de nuit
présent aux chevaux des patients
si l'intention qui a présidé à
l'élaboration de ce texte et tout à fait
légitime son adoption risquerait de
nuire à l'objectif et finalement à
affaiblir la réponse aux besoins de
santé de nos concitoyens
lors de son discours de vœux aux acteurs
de la santé le président de la
République a réaffirmé avec conviction
notre méthode pour parvenir à redonner
du sens et de l'appliquer au travail des
soignants notre méthode pour combattre
les effets de l'érosion de la
démographie médicale c'est de travailler
à de meilleurs organisations collectives
pour favoriser la cohésion de la
communauté hospitalière et pour y
arriver nous devons permettre plus de
liberté d'organisation plus d'agilité
pour que chaque service et la capacité
d'adapter son fonctionnement en temps
réel aux besoins rencontrés notre
objectif est ainsi d'arriver à établir
un modèle dans lequel les solutions se
construisent localement à partir de la
charge en soins constaté et des leviers
disponibles pour y répondre
c'est pour cela que nous insistons avec
François Brown sur la place du service
qu'il faut conforter et renforcer au
cœur de l'hôpital c'est bien cet échelon
qu'il convient d'investir pour
réinsuffler de la souplesse et retrouver
de la pertinence dans des organisations
du temps de travail construite avec les
soignants
l'établissement de ratio fixes sur une
base nationale par la Haute Autorité de
Santé est à l'opposé de cette méthode
même en raisonnant par spécialité même
en résonant par type d’activité les
besoins de chaque service ne seront
jamais les mêmes au même moment
tout comme les capacités et le levier
disponibles qui sont différents en
fonction des établissements et de leur
spécificité notre réponse ne doit pas
être de simplifier standardiser des
effectifs mais au contraire de mieux
allouer des ressources humaines de les
mettre au bon endroit au bon moment
j'insiste sur ce terme de ressources qui
prend en compte bien sûr le nombre des
soignants mais aussi leurs compétences
et leurs expertises
il ne s'agit pas ici de résoudre une
équation trop longtemps il a été
reproché aux hôpitaux une gestion trop
normée basée sur des tableurs Excel or
ce n'est pas avec ces tableurs Excel que
nous répondrons à cet enjeu c'est en se
basant sur une évaluation au cas par cas
de la charge en soins et du niveau de
ressources adaptée à cette charge en
soins que nous y arriverons
avec des ajustements spécifiques à la
main de ceux qui connaissent le mieux
les besoins et les capacités de leurs
équipes à y répondre le binôme chef de
service cadre de santé est à ce titre
fondamental il nous faut le soutenir
avec le ministre de la santé et de la
prévention nous voulons réaffirmer la
confiance que nous avons dans ce binôme
managérial dans le cadre de la
transformation de l'hôpital que nous
menons pour qu'il puisse pleinement se
saisir de leur mission de garant de
qualité de soins et de la stabilité des
collectifs de leurs services afin qu'il
ne s'agisse plus pour les managers
d'organiser des cadences et un travail à
flux tendu mais de bâtir de nouveaux
modèles de développement plus souple
plus adaptés aux contraintes et plus
participatives cette confiance cette
marge d'action et cette liberté
d'organisation elles sont aussi majeures
pour que chacun se sente mieux reconnu
et valorisé dans son travail et nous
savons qu'un soignant qui se sent bien
est un soignant qui soit le mieux c'est
aussi un enjeu important de fidélisation
des professionnels pour que les
carrières à l'hôpital public retrouvent
des perspectives et toute leur activité
c'est comme cela que nous agirons
réellement pour répondre à cette double
exigence de répondre de réponse locale
aux besoins des patients et de garantie
quant à la qualité de vie des soignants
il ne s'agit pas ici de trouver des
chemins détournés pour ignorer ou éviter
de traiter les problèmes oui certains
services sont confrontés à une situation
d'insuffisance chronique de personnelle
oui le manque de soignants est une
réalité dans certains services et dans
certains modes d'exercices pour le
travail de nuit notamment nous devons
prendre le sujet avant un corps avec
pragmatisme nous avons le devoir de
trouver les moyens d'y faire face à très
court terme toutefois même s'ils étaient
mis en place avec les meilleures
intentions du monde la question ne se
règlerait pas en décrétant des ratios
dans la loi avec François Brune nous
restons fidèles à nos convictions la
coercition n'est pas un mode de
résolution des problèmes dans les
territoires
dans la mise en adéquation des effectifs
avec la réalité des besoins nous en
appelons également à la responsabilité
de chacun
responsabilisation des directions qui
doivent donner des outils adaptés aux
équipes et responsabilisation des
équipes de terrain pour se saisir de ses
outils
je parlais de combattre les effets de la
diminution de la démographie médicale et
des difficultés d'attractivité des
métiers de la santé c'est ce à quoi nous
sommes attelés à très court terme car
c'est l'urgence c'est un travail que
nous venons parallèlement et de manière
complémentaire aux efforts structurels
pour nous attaquer aux causes de
l'érosion de la ressource soignante et
augmenter durablement le nombre des
professionnels de santé nous l'avons
appelé lors de nos vœux aux forces vives
lundi notre objectif s'est formé plus de
soignants et de les former mieux je
pense bien sûr à la suppression du
numerusclosus pour les médecins je pense
au travail que nous menons avec les
régions pour remplir des objectifs
quantitatifs et qualitatifs en termes de
formation de nouveaux infirmiers et
infirmières dans des cursus rénovés et
sécurisés je pense à la libération des
voies d'accès aux métiers du soin au
développement de l'apprentissage au VAE
aux contrats d'engagement et de services
publics qui vont se multiplier
je pense aussi aux travaux que nous
menons pour améliorer le quotidien des
soignants et mieux prendre en compte la
pénibilité
l'extension de la prime de soins
critiques que nous avons déjà décidé
pour reconnaître la mobilisation de tous
les soignants de ses services les
mesures dédiées au travail de nuit prise
depuis l'été considérant que cet effort
ne va plus de soi aujourd'hui alors même
que l'hôpital ne peut jamais s'arrêter
la mobilisation dans les territoires des
leviers locaux d'attractivité pour
faciliter la vie quotidienne de nos
soignants qu'il s'agisse de leur
logement de leur transport de leur
stationnement ou de la garde de leurs
enfants
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
le voyez bien notre politique en la
matière est globale elle fait se
rencontrer les nécessités urgentes avec
les chantiers de plus long terme elle
nous permet à la fois de rénover le mode
de fonctionnement de nos services
hospitaliers à court terme et de
travailler à sécuriser leurs effectifs
sur le long terme
je disais que décréter des ratios dans
la loi ne règlerait rien à ces deux
enjeux conjoints je crois même que leur
rigidité intrinsèque serait de nature à
aggraver les problèmes qu'ils entendent
résoudre en effet une fois les ratios
établies plusieurs questions très
concrètes émergent d'emblée que se
passe-t-il si l'hôpital n'arrive pas à
recruter suffisamment pour respecter les
ratios imposés par la loi je la firme
établir des ratios qu'on dira
enivitablement à des réorganisations de
l'offre de soins avec des effets
collatéraux nécessitant des rappels de
personnels des fermetures de lit et dans
les cas les plus difficiles des
fermetures de services mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs élus de terrain
vous avez plein de conscience de ces
réalités locales vous êtes nombreux à
nous alerter à nous écrire à nous
interpeller sur la situation de certains
services de proximité dans vos
territoires
si la plupart des services sont tenus
face aux tensions de notre système de
santé cet été comme cet hiver c'est
parce que les soignants se sont
mobilisés avec le soutien des ARS pour
faire face et adapter leurs
fonctionnements ils ont su trouver des
solutions managériales pour reconfigurer
leurs organisations travailler avec la
médecine de ville pour des engorger les
hôpitaux et mobiliser le territoire en
appui au fonctionnement des
établissements
sidérations rigides avaient été en place
de nombreux hôpitaux locaux et services
de proximité seraient aujourd'hui fermés
avec des conséquences très dures en
termes de prise en charge à l'image des
Assises de la pédiatrie et de la santé
dans l'enfant les chantiers que nous
avons ouvert et que j'ai mentionné doit
venir soulager ces tensions mais c'est
dans un cadre managérial ouvert et
flexible basé sur l'évaluation de la
charge en soins réel que doivent se
décliner ces changements et se déployer
les nouveaux soignants que nous formons
en ce moment même
ensuite le sujet des ratios pose des
questions éthiques et juridiques
majeures que faire quand un patient se
présente et que sa prise en charge ne
rentre pas dans la fraction soignée
soignant préétabli que se passe-t-il si
un hôpital décide de prendre en charge
un patient alors qu'il ne reste pas
respecte pas les ratiaux inscrits dans
la loi notre mission c'est bien
d'assurer la continuité des prises en
charge 7 jours sur 7 et 24 heures sur 24
pour cela il faut pouvoir s'adapter aux
situations pour proposer la solution la
plus efficace et la plus sûre aux
malades qui doivent être prises en
charge imposer mécaniquement des ratios
fragiliseraient la sécurité juridique
des établissements il faut se rendre
compte que c'est la responsabilité de
l'hôpital et de sa direction qui serait
directement mis en cause pour tout
fonctionnement en dessous des mesures
fixées par la loi y compris en cas
d'absentéisme prévu enfin je constate
que le dispositif juridique envisagé
aujourd'hui ne s'applique qu'aux
établissements de santé assurant des
missions de service public alors que
nous appliquons par ailleurs à des
cloisonner notre système de santé en
imposant la rigidité de ratio à notre
hôpital le texte aggraverait les
inégalités et disparités entre public et
privés que nous combattons mesdames et
messieurs vous l'aurez compris le
Gouvernement est défavorable à l'article
unique de la proposition de loi que nous
examinons cette position ne correspond
en rien à renoncement ou à une
hésitation à prendre une position de
fermeté jamais nous ne reculerons devant
les mesures nécessaires pour améliorer
l'accès aux soins et conforter les
effectifs au lit des patients cette
position est un choix c'est un choix
assumé car nous ne croyons pas à la
coercition à la centralisation et au
modèle unique cette position n'est pas
un refus c'est une proposition qui
s'inscrit dans une politique globale
sert de tout faire pour redonner
confiance à nos professionnels et pour
leur redonner envie de s'engager à
l'hôpital celle de sécuriser les
collectifs de travail en luttant contre
l'intérim cannibale celle de donner les
moyens aux acteurs de proximité à celles
et ceux qui soient au quotidien de
travailler en fonction de besoin et de
leur contrainte en leur laissant la
marge de manœuvre nécessaire pour cela
cette position c'est celle de la
confiance envers les professionnels de
santé confiance je le répète qui sera
accompagnée par le gouvernement dans le
cadre de la réforme hospitalière et de
l'effort inédit de formation que nous
menons cette position c'est vous dire le
travail est pleinement engagé cette
proposition de loi est légitime dans ses
objectifs il nous faut œuvrer ensemble à
une meilleure évaluation des charges de
travail de nos soignants à redonner du
temps aux professionnels de santé pour
que nos précieuses ressources humaines
soient en adéquation avec les besoins
des patients au service de la santé de
la population
associons nos communautés soignantes
faisons confiance au terrain en sa
capacité à trouver et à co-construire
des solutions je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à Monsieur Olivier Hainaut pour le
groupe Union centriste pour 6 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la Présidente de commission
madame la rapporteur l'auteur de la loi
mes chers collègues j'ai écouté avec
attention les interventions qui m'ont
précédé celle de Bernard jaumier de La
rapporteur de Madame la Ministre et
j'avoue être partagé à l'image des votes
des membres de notre groupe je ne doute
pas de la bonne intention de l'auteur de
cette proposition de loi je comprends
aussi par cette membres pourquoi cette
PPL est discutée dans cette hémicycle
notre présidente Catherine Deroche l'a
très bien rappelé en commission cette
PPL résulte en partie de la commission
d'enquête sur l'hôpital et de ses
conclusions qui a constaté mais on le
savait la dégradation de notre système
hospitalier et l'extrême lassitude de
nos soignants
donc pour ce qui me concerne ce sera un
oui mais oui oui car la crise de la
covid-19 a été éreintante pour nos
soignants nombre d'entre eux ont été
surmenés c'est cette proposition de loi
va dans le bon sens elle s'inscrit dans
un climat toujours aussi tendu pour nos
soignants aujourd'hui en cas de survenue
d'un accident médical par exemple du
fait d'un manque de personnel ou de
demande de dommage et intérêt du patient
le juge pourra retenir la responsabilité
de l'établissement de santé si l'estime
que le nombre d'infirmiers présents
n'était pas adapté aux contraintes de
service que ce défaut d'organisation a
été à l'origine d'un préjudice pour le
patient il est donc nécessaire de
réformer et d'anticiper cette
proposition de loi se base notamment sur
des expériences étrangères menées en
Australie en Californie ça a été dit
avec des résultats parfois significatifs
sur les qualités des soins et le
bien-être au travail du personnel
soignant
en même temps mes chers collègues il y a
quand même quelque chose de terrible
d'évoquer ici des exemples en Australie
aux États-Unis pour comparer notre
système de santé je pense pas qu'on
aurait évoqué des exemples comme
celui-là il y a encore quelques années
mais c'est une remarque comme l'analyse
la rapporteur la proposition de loi se
veut être une loi de programmation il
n'est donc pas réaliste de prévoir une
mise en oeuvre du dispositif proposé en
seulement quelques mois et d'ailleurs
les expériences montrent que le temps
requis par de tels changements ou
qu'elle s'ajoute le temps nécessaire au
recrutement et à la formation et au
financement des postes si cette
proposition de loi laisse jusqu'au 31
décembre 2024 à la Haute Autorité de
Santé pour redéfinir ses ratios en vue
d'une application réglementaire à
compter du 1er janvier 2027 il ne faut
pas se tromper sur les besoins d'une
telle réforme dans le système
hospitalier l'attractivité la
rémunération le bien-être doivent être
des sujets travaillés en profondeur car
s'ils sont aujourd'hui le cœur d'un
système de santé qui s'essouffle
aujourd'hui selon plusieurs organisation
près de 10% des emplois infirmiers sont
eau pourvus l'instauration d'un nombre
minimum de soignants par patience
ficcialier suffira-t-elle à résoudre à
court terme la pénurie de personnel
c'est pas sûr du tout et donc oui mais
oui mais parce que au-delà du manque de
professionnels de soignants disponibles
sur le marché du travail ce dont les
soignants ont besoin hors rémunération
ce sont des conditions de travail où ils
savent qu'ils pourront se sentir utile
et s'épanouir en toute confiance parce
que les ratios s'apprécient souvent
beaucoup plus sur le plan quantitatif
que qualitatif ils sont quand même une
réponse approximative et d'ailleurs
beaucoup ne s'y trompent pas les
Français et comme dans beaucoup de
domaines la défiance dans notre système
de santé s'est installé plus largement
mais chaque collègue je veux vous faire
partager quelques questions je ne pense
pas que le remède au mal de notre
système de santé résulte dans la
multiplicité des initiatives
législatives ou parlementaires je vous
déjà je vais vous ai déjà fait partager
cette réflexion lors du débat sur le
PLFSS de novembre dernier j'ai même
parfois l'impression que toutes ces
initiatives toujours bien intentionnées
certes participent à stresser le système
et à désespérer les soignants mais doute
sur cette PPL nos doutes concernent
aussi le principe même des ratios la
notion de ratio de rationnement fait
souvent toujours écho à la notion
pénurie mais c'est rarement le remède à
la pénurie en vérité notre système de
santé autrefois une fierté française est
aujourd'hui en grande souffrance en
extrême fragilité je crois beaucoup plus
à une grande loi santé qui remettrait
tout à plat et viserait à redonner du
sens au travail le sens du travail est
d'ailleurs la question clé pour la
société française d'aujourd'hui y
compris sur la question des retraites
enfin dernière question il y a un grand
risque à mettre le doigt dans
l'engrenage de la société de ratio des
ratios pour les soignants
demain des ratios pour les enseignants
pour la police pourquoi pas pour les
services publics y compris pourquoi pas
pour les services publics municipaux et
la bon courage j'y vois un grand risque
et donc pour conclure je pense que la
question abordée est une bonne question
elle est posée par cette PPL car le
Ségur de la santé n'a pas calmé n'a pas
résolu le malaise de l'hôpital mais en
revanche j'ai un vrai doute et nous
avons un vrai doute notre groupe a un
vrai doute sur la pertinence de la
réponse je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Madame Véronique Guillotin
pour le groupe RDSE pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la Présidente de commission
madame la rapporteur chers collègues
cette proposition de loi vise à établir
des ratios de patients par soignants
dans les hôpitaux publics et les
établissements privés à but non lucratif
elle entend ainsi apporter une réponse
aux difficultés de l'hôpital en
instaurant d'une part une base légale
claire au ratio de sécurité déjà
existant dans certains services
réanimations soins continus et en créant
d'autres parts des ratiosités
qualitatifs décrit par notre rapporteur
comme des fourchettes ciblatteindre
adaptées au contexte locaux mes chers
collègues l'hôpital va mal les soignants
le kit et délit ferme on ne compte plus
les exemples de patients restés 24 48
heures sur des brancards dans les
couloirs des urgences on ne compte plus
les témoignages de patients qui ont
quelquefois le sentiment d'avoir été
maltraité car oui le système actuel est
maltraitant pour les patients comme pour
les soignants ces métiers ou souvent
l'humain est au cœur de la vocation et
revenir au coeur de la pratique pour
cela il faut plus d'effectifs dans les
services c'est certain c'est l'un des
vœux exprimés par le Président de la
République début janvier et là-dessus
personne ne le contredira car la
situation pénalise tout le monde les
patients qui font face à des risques
accrus infections
plus fréquentes voire mortalité plus
élevée les soignants qui eux doivent
gérer de plus en plus de patients en
étant de moins en moins nombreux ce qui
aboutit à une perte de sens des arrêts
maladie et des démissions en pagaille
les soignants réclament avant tout une
amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail et notamment plus de temps
consacré aux patients
aussi l'intention de nos collègues et
louables et nous souscrivons évidemment
aux objectifs poursuivis qui sont
d'améliorer l'accueil des patients et
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
des soignants pour autant de nombreuses
questions et des doutes quand on s'en à
son efficacité se posent la première
d'entre elles et la crainte de voir
davantage de service fermé faute de
parvenir à atteindre ses nouveaux
ratiaux la rapporteur a évoqué un délai
de trois jours pour alerter la RS en cas
d'incapacité à satisfaire les rations
qualitatifs trois jours et ensuite la RS
devra-t-elle aider l'établissement à
trouver une solution ou devra lui
imposer de faire mes délits comment la
RS pourrait-elle trouver des soignants
quand les responsables des
établissements ni parviennent pas les
hôpitaux ne seront-ils pas tentés de
recourir davantage à l'intérim alors que
nous tentons presque vainement pour
l'heure d'y mettre un coup d'arrêt
malheureusement les soignants
n'apparaîtront pas d'un coup de baguette
magique aujourd'hui les établissements
veulent recruter mais il n'y a pas de
candidats c'est pourquoi nous devons
former davantage de personnes et en même
temps améliorer l'attractivité des
métiers c'est un chantier urgent à mener
avec les régions pour augmenter le
nombre de places de formation dans les
ifs si redonner du sens au métier
réfléchir sur les validations d'acquis
d’expérience développer la voie de
l'alternance encore insuffisamment
utilisé et revoir le financement des
formations dans le cadre d'un parcours
professionnel
améliorer la qualité de vie au travail
c'est aussi revoir le financement et
l'organisation des hôpitaux s'ils Ségure
de la santé n'a pas été le déclencheur
espéré il y a urgence à réformer la
tarification à l'activité à sortir des
indicateurs comme la réduction de la
durée moyenne de ces jours par exemple
car je crois que sans une vision à 360
degrés
sortant d'une accumulation de
différentes propositions projets divers
et variés qui ont toutes un intérêt
certain cette PPL risque d'être
incantatoire j'entends l'importance
d'envoyer un signal positif au soignants
mais je crois encore plus à la nécessité
d'être efficace je crois qu'on ne peut
plus vendre aujourd'hui du rêve au
patient et aux soignants vous l'aurez
compris si nous partageons l'intention
louable de cette PPL une partie de mon
groupe reste sceptique sur ses effets
réels et une bonne partie du groupe
s'abstiendra
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Madame Catherine Berry
Bellucci pour le groupe les républicains
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègue le dévouement des
soignants dans le contexte récent d'une
crise sanitaire et à présent d'un
fonctionnement normal des établissements
de santé et des hôpitaux est exemplaire
outre la profonde reconnaissance de la
nation il exige également un soutien
renforcé le rapport d'information
réalisé à la demande du groupe les
républicains et par notre collègue
Catherine Deroche concernant l'hôpital
et le système de santé nous y inviter
déjà il y a moins d'un an à partir d'un
état des lieux précis et de
recommandations concrètes
la proportionnalité des moyens
hospitaliers étaient déjà au centre des
préoccupations compte tenues de
l'évolution des défis de la santé et du
système de soins parmi les
préconisations formulées l'amélioration
des capacités d'accueil des services
d'urgence devaient retenir toute notre
attention aujourd'hui la conversion
d'une de ces recommandations en
proposition de loi nous oblige
le taux d'encadrement des patients la
définition de standard capacitaire et
l'utilisation d'indicateurs fiables pour
soutenir nos hôpitaux doivent être
renforcés en premier lieu ses avancées
conditionnent un meilleur pilotage de
nos politiques de santé il s'agit d'un
impératif pour préciser les besoins des
hôpitaux et pouvoir leur affecter les
moyens les plus utiles les derniers
textes financiers budgétaires ont
notamment permis de préserver les
budgets hospitaliers de toute économie
malvenu
une rallonge de 1,1 milliard a également
été ajouté au soutien des hôpitaux afin
de permettre une bonne exécution
budgétaire et une pleine efficacité de
nos politiques de santé la nécessité se
fait donc sentir de disposer
d'indicateurs fiables que la présente
proposition de loi contribue utilement à
déterminer en deuxième lieu il est
nécessaire que la situation et les
seuils concernant l'activité
hospitalière se traduisent par des
objectifs réalistes je voudrais insister
sur ce point car il a fait l'objet de la
plus grande attention et du meilleur
engagement du groupe les républicains en
commission d'une part la fixation de
ratio minimaux notamment entre le nombre
des soignants et le nombre de lit ouvert
exprime concrètement le souci d'un
accueil rationalisé des patients jusque
dans les services d'urgence
un tel ratio doit effectivement inclure
les personnels de santé effectivement
disponibles pour les patients depuis les
infirmiers jusqu'aux aides-soignants
d'autre part ces ratios doivent être
encore plus réalistes les fixer de
manière aveugle dans tous les services
en période de pénurie consisterait à
rompre en pratique les promesses de
soutien formulés dans nos lois le groupe
LR c'est donc attaché à adapter ses
seuils à deux égards non seulement afin
de garantir qu'ils pourront être
praticables au sein des hôpitaux afin de
ne pas les soumettre à des objectifs
illusoire
mais surtout afin de lier ces objectifs
à une croissance des moyens hospitaliers
sur les années à venir c'est la raison
pour laquelle les ratios feront l'objet
d'une double adaptation ils pourront
tout d'abord être moduler compte tenu
des circonstances locales liées à la
population aux effectifs des hôpitaux et
au moyen disponibles ils seront plus
encore lissés sur les années à venir
suivant l'application d'une politique de
santé réaliste soucieuse d'accompagner
ensemble les patients les soignants et
les établissements les amendements
adoptés en commission doivent être à cet
égard salués en troisième et dernier
lieu ces ratios constituent plus que des
conditions d'application de notre
politique de santé et de renforcement de
nos établissements hospitaliers
il porte également une forte charge
symbolique pour nos soignants nos chefs
de services et d'établissements ils
apportent la première pierre un souci de
précision et de soutien de nos hôpitaux
les professions de santé nous allons
conscience relève d'une vocation d'un
service public qui ne doit pas être
synonyme de sacrifice permanent pour
ceux qui l'accomplissent au quotidien
leurs conditions de travail se doivent
être attentivement préservés et nos
travaux parlementaires le montrent plus
renforcés que jamais
c'est d'autant plus le cas grâce aux
objectifs de la présente loi qui ne
s'accompagnent en pratique d'aucun
affaiblissement du service hospitalier
et d'aucune fermeture de lit comme notre
collègue rapporteur Laurent site Le
Rossignol l'a déjà démontré
précisez l'équilibre entre le nombre de
soignants et leur patients poursuit donc
un double objectif quant à notre service
public hospitalier d'une part
l'assurance d'une meilleure amélioration
quantitative qualitative des soins pour
nos patients comme pour nous soignants
et d'autre part l'accompagnement d'une
augmentation quantitative des moyens
hospitaliers dont bénéficieront à
nouveau hôpitaux et patients ensemble je
vous remercie merci
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Daniel Chassin pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 4 minutes
je suis le président madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de commission
madame la remporteur mes chers collègues
la pandémie que nous avons connue en
2000 20 a permis de mettre en lumière
les difficultés majeures que rencontrent
les soignants à l'hôpital ces
difficultés étaient déjà bien présentes
avant la crise manque de personnel
rappelle pendant les jours de repos et
puis la crise de covid n'a fait
qu'aggraver ses problèmes mais beaucoup
de soignants ont choisi de quitter leur
profession pour changer de voix c'est
des parts des grades encore davantage
des conditions de travail de ceux qui
restent faisant courir le risque de
départ en cascade le seigneur de la
Santé a permis de revaloriser leur
rémunération c'était très important mais
cela n'a malheureusement pas suffi à
endiguer les départs ni à augmenter le
nombre de soignants
présent auprès des patients parfois
d'ailleurs les postes financés ne sont
pas pourvu cette proposition de loi vise
à établir et à garantir en ratio minima
de soignants par nombre de lits ouverts
dans les services hospitaliers et les
activités ambulatoire afin d'assurer au
patients une prise en charge de qualité
et de bonne condition de travail aux
soignants aujourd'hui de telles ratio
existent mais seulement pour certains
services sera animation néonatalogie
soit intensive etc or un nombre minimum
de personnels soignants et nécessaires
quel que soit le service d'abord avoir
le temps nécessaire pour les
aides-soignante par exemple d'effectuer
des changes des soins de peau mais aussi
pour dialoguer porter intérêt aux
patients car prendre soin n'est pas
seulement faire des soins c'est aussi
considérer le patient comme une personne
qui doit être écoutée et informé pour
les infirmiers ou infirmières ne pas
réaliser des soins au pas de course
avoir le temps nécessaire pour observer
dans tourner l'évolution d'État général
du patient en fonction de sa pathologie
les soignants aiment leur métier il doit
être de soins mais aussi d'écouter de
bienveillance ils sont souvent
découragés par une impossibilité
d'effectuer correctement à cause d'une
charge trop lourde de travail et de
manque de temps malgré les augmentations
du Ségur le manque de personnel des
cadences sont trop élevés le travail
n'est pas attractif la fidélisation du
personnel tient aussi à la qualité des
conditions de travail nous devons donc
former beaucoup plus de soignants bien
sûr le terme de ratio peut faire peur
car il laisse parfois penser à des
règles uniformes strictes qui ne Pen qui
ne tiennent pas compte de la réalité
propre à chaque établissement cette PPL
ne doit certainement pas conduire à
fermer des lits à cause de
mais de ratio ni des services et ces
ratios devront être appliquées avec
souplesse car les malades effectivement
doivent être prises en charge le texte
prévoit justement
d'associer les commissions médicales et
les soins infirmés chargés d'approuver
l'organisation des soins en fonction des
ratios en tenant compte des contraintes
des établissements un tel texte aurait
pu également trouver tout son sens dans
une application aux EHPAD ou le
personnel est insuffisant pour prendre
en charge décemment nous aînés devenus
très dépendant situation qui va
s'aggraver d'ici 2030 nous attendons
donc avec impatience sa réalisation d'un
plan grand âge avec 50 000 emplois
supplémentaires annoncé par le président
de la République ce qui ferait passer
l'encadrement des soignants de 0,3 à 0,4
par pensionnaire environ 5 emplois de
plus par EHPAD c'est très attendu par
les familles et les travailleurs en
attendant
nous sommes favorables à cette PPL qui a
l'objectif d'éviter d'épuisement et le
découragement du personnel d'améliorer
la prise en charge globale des patients
par plus d'écoute et de surveillance et
ainsi rendre de nouveau attractifs très
beau métier de soignant merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Madame Raymond de poncer
mon ange pour le groupe écologiste pour
4 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègue nous les avons
applaudis depuis nos fenêtres après des
années de rationnement les soignants
exigent une perspective de sortie à la
crise traversée par l'hôpital public le
spectre de la dégradation des conditions
de travail est vastes heures
supplémentaires subies travaillent
morcelé pressé compressé vétusté des
équipements ballotements de services en
service afin de pallier le manque de
personnel à rebours d'une situation qui
empire cette proposition de loi se veut
aussi un signal envoyé aux soignants
elle ouvre une fenêtre sur un horizon
attendu d'effectifs suffisant dans
chaque service les ratios de soignants
permettent d'améliorer tant la sécurité
la qualité de soi que la qualité de vie
au travail ils sont une partie de la
solution il protège de faire des
effectifs la variable d'ajustement des
contraintes budgétaires et limite les
changements incessants de service en
service des professionnels qui
gaspillent spécialisation des faits les
collectifs et produits souffrances et
perte de sens dans une lettre ouverte
d'attente 2022 je crois que ça a été
cité le collège de la Haute Autorité de
Santé a souligné l'importance d'équipe
stable partageant une culture commune de
qualité et de sécurité de soins pour
autant les résultats positifs imputés
aux ratio est-il internationales à
l'appui sont toujours corrélés donc
conditionnés à l'augmentation des
effectifs soignants le présent texte
prévoit un mécanisme d'alerte en cas de
constatation d'une incapacité à
respecter les ratios qualitatifs au-delà
de trois jours que se passera-t-il
ensuite qui aura la responsabilité de
sortir de l'injonction paradoxale
des ratios qualitatifs vicieux existent
déjà et ils sont inappliqués tant par
les soignants que par les directeurs
d'établissements pour des raisons
structurelles et profondes la
distinction entre introduite entre ratio
de qualité et ratio de sécurité démontre
la difficulté de l'équation et de son
application la sécurité des patients et
la qualité des soins sont imbriquées en
l'état et en l'état du système de santé
les garanties les garantir relèvent
d'une grande loi les fédérations
hospitalières craignent une équation
impossible ne leur soit imposée de plus
qu'au secteur public ou privé non
lucratif en l'état la crainte de
fermeture de lit ou de services n'est
pas négligée d'autant que le niveau
d'absentéisme se stabilise à un niveau
plus élevé qu'avant la crise sanitaire
par conséquent si nous soutenons
l'instauration de la référence de ratio
dans le secteur sanitaire et appelons
d'ailleurs à son extension dans le champ
médico-social nous estimons fondamental
bon bien sûr que cette mesure soit
conditionnée à une traduction budgétaire
forte notamment dans la dame enfin
défini à partir des besoins des besoins
de soins des besoins de ce mais aussi de
la qualité de vie au travail des
soignants et qu'elles suivent un
calendrier réaliste afin de former de
recruter d'augmenter des salaires et
bien d'autres conditions aussi plus
globalement l'édiction de quota devra
prendre sa place dans une grande loi
santé loi très attendue car seul en
mesure de donner tous son sens et son
efficience à ses propositions comme
aujourd'hui indéniablement positive tout
en maîtrisant les effets Collator
collatéraux préjudiciable qui explique
une partie des réticences en attendant
nous les avons applaudis nous répondons
donc à leur appel afin d'envoyer un
signal fort de soutien aux soignants qui
majoritairement
réclame l'instauration d'un nombre
minimum de soignants par patience
hospitalisé le groupe écologiste votera
cette proposition de loi
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur Abdallah Sani pour
le groupe RDPI pour 4 minutes
le président madame la ministre chers
collègue comment ne pas partager
l'objectif de réduire la charge des
personnels soignants que l'on sait
épuisé
les inciter à rester dans nos hôpitaux
ou faire revenir ce qu'ils ont quitté le
test qui nous est soumis vise aussi à
assurer une prise en charge de qualité à
nos concitoyens grâce à un encadrement
adéquat là aussi nous partageons le but
mais elle c'est le meilleur chemin
présenter comme souple il risque plutôt
de rigidifier l'organisation au sein des
hôpitaux là où justement nous nous
efforçons de créer de l'agilité pour
aller au plus proche des besoins
territoriaux des ratios de sécurité
existent déjà pour certains services
mais conditions prévues les capacités
d'accueil sont suspendus ou réduites le
principe serait acté par la loi alors
qu'ils sont jusqu'à présent d'ordre
réglementaires
le président du Sénat parlé il y a peu
de sobriété législatives
pourquoi voter une mesure législative
qui relève bien davantage du décret le
test propose de créer d'autres ratios
dit de qualité sur la base de
recommandations de la Haute Autorité de
Santé une révision aurait lieu tous les
5 ans le nord-est des ratiaux
qualitatifs au-delà des trois jours
serait signalé à l'ARS
que fera-t-on alors
quelle responsabilité pour les pour les
établissements ne parvena pas à
atteindre ces ratios les sécurités
juridiques d'un tel dispositif et les
risques pour les la pérennité des
services sont à noter présenter comme
une loi de programmation l'application
se fera en deux temps n'est-ce pas faire
une inquiétude sur les acteurs à court
terme
alors oui je l'ai dit partageons tous la
volonté de proposer des solutions aux
soignants mais ce qu'il souhaite à mon
sens ce sont des engagements concrets
plus que de rigidité à long terme je
pense au revalorisation du Ségur aux
mesures de compensation de la pénibilité
notamment du travail de nuit prise
depuis l'été ou encore au 19 milliards
d'euros pour l'investissement en santé
en tout cas je peux vous le dire à
Mayotte l'hôpital est en main
considérable des soignants et la
pression de l'activité reste très tendue
au regard des capacités je crains que
ces ratio ne soit pas la réponse
adéquate face à l'ampleur de la tâche
c'était dans les intentions sont certes
louables ne peut donc pas à tout état de
cause être une réponse globale au défi à
relever
il pourrait plutôt conduire à
complexifier notre système de santé et
amener un résultat inverse à cellules
recherchée c'est pourquoi le groupe est
des pays s'absent
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant madame Émilie rôle pour
le groupe socialiste pour 6 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
le rapporteur cher Laurence Rossignol
chers collègues lapl que nous examinons
aujourd'hui vise à établir un ratio
minimum de soignants par passion au sein
des services d'hôpital public le constat
nous le connaissons le partageons
fermeture de services annulation
d'opération programmée des missions de
personnes soignants l'hôpital public et
son personnel sont depuis des années en
souffrance et j'irai même en détresse
les périodes de crise de tension dans
les services hospitalistes succèdent et
le séjour et le Ségur la santé qui a
certes permis une revalorisation
salariale apparaît comme une réponse
insuffisante face à l'ampleur des
difficultés que rencontre l'hôpital en
effet plus que le trop faible niveau de
rémunération ce sont les conditions de
travail dégradé le manque de médical
auprès des patients que dénoncent les
soignants et qui entraînent le départ
des professionnels et ainsi près de 10%
des postes d'infirmières ne sont pas
aujourd'hui pourvues et pour cause ce
sont aujourd'hui les contraintes
budgétaires et non les besoins en soins
qui déterminent le nombre d'infirmières
dans les services et la composition de
l'équipe de soin pourtant nous le savons
le personnel infirmier les
aide-soignants jouent un rôle essentiel
dans la qualité des soins et les études
scientifiques le montrent la mortalité
des patients augmente dès qu'une
infirmière doit s'occuper de plus de six
patients or dans nos hôpitaux une
infirmière est dans la plupart des
services en charge de 15 patients dans
la journée 24 patients la nuit il
apparaît donc indispensable de repenser
l'organisation du travail à l'hôpital de
changer de paradigme de London et de
garantir un nombre suffisant de
professionnels de santé par patient
quel est l'objet du texte que nous
présentons assurer un info à une prise
en charge de qualité pour les patients
et de bonnes conditions de vie au
travail pour les soignants il permettra
de redonner de l'attractivité et du sens
au travail pour l'ensemble des
personnels cette PPL est le fruit d'un
travail de plusieurs années d'audition
de concertation avec le personnel
hospitalier en particulier avec le
collectif interhospitalier dans le cadre
du référendum d'initiative partagée
hôpital et je remercie notre collègue
Bernard jaumier de présenter ce texte
aujourd'hui notre BPL sans prétendre
résoudre l'ensemble bien sûr des
difficultés d’hôpital représentent une
réelle avancée en fixant FX exercices un
objectif de rétablissement d'effectif
suffisant auprès des patients et charge
la chaise de définir par spécialité et
par type d'activité un ratio minimal de
soignants par lit ouvert ou par nombre
de passages pour les activités
ambulatoires
au cours des auditions menées par notre
rapporteur Laurence Rossignol nous avons
entendu à la fois l'approbation et
l'espoir soulever par l'ensemble pour
l'ensemble des soignants infirmiers
aide-soignante professionnelle
mais aussi nous avons entendu les
interrogations des directions
hospitalières cela amené notre
rapporteur à modifier l'article unique
en précisant les modalités et le
calendrier de l'entrée en vigueur ainsi
le texte est pensé comme une loi de
programmation il définit une cible à
atteindre avec une entrée en vigueur
progressive cela permettra ainsi
d'évaluer au plus près la charge de
soins pour les différents postes charges
qui nous savons dépend de nombreux
facteurs nous l'avons entendu et compris
non seulement dans les différentes
spécialités mais aussi dans les
différentes territoires et parfois même
en fonction de l'architecture des
bâtiments des politiques de ratio par
patient nous en avons l'expérience
d'abord dans les services où c'est
obligatoire mais il y a aussi eu
des services plus simples de les
expériences faites en Australie et aux
États-Unis qui ont montré qu'il existe
bien en lien certains entre une
augmentation de la dotation en
infirmière et la diminution de la durée
du séjour des réadmissions de la
mortalité des erreurs médicales et même
de la démission du personnel infirmier
alors oui cette mesure va être coûteuse
et elle va nécessiter un fort
investissement de l'État mais les études
scientifiques le montrent à moyen et à
long terme augmenter le nombre de
personnels soignant constituent un
investissement positif en termes
financier en effet selon cette étude
australienne engager un nombre suffisant
d'infirmières représenter un coût total
de 33 millions de dollars sur deux ans
mais il a permis d'éviter une dépense de
69 millions de dollars en coup de
réadimissions et de durée de séjour
Institut des ratios soignants par
passion a donc nous le voyons un triple
bénéfice pour la santé et la sécurité
des patients pour redonner du sens et
une qualité de vie au travail et aux
personnels soignants pour faire des
économies en coût éviter en moyenne et à
long terme mais encore une fois c'est un
choix politique que nous avons à faire
aujourd'hui soit investir dans l'hôpital
public le service public de la santé
pour garantir une prise en charge de
qualité à chacun ou alors laisser la loi
du marché et la rentabilité de la santé
des Français nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui d'agir réellement pour
l'avenir du service public et madame la
ministre il s'agit nullement d'une
mesure de coercition mais d'un travail
en concertation qui tient compte des
différentes contraintes que vous avez
évoquées
merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Laurence Cohen pour le
groupe CRCE pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier le travail de la
rapporteur Laurence Rossignol sur cette
proposition de loi déposée par le groupe
socialiste qui vise à instaurer un nom
minimal de soignants infirmiers
aide-soignant par patient hospitalisé
notre collègue Bernard jaumier à
l'initiative de ce texte reprend ici une
revendication portée par des collectifs
de personnels soignants depuis plusieurs
années en France il existe déjà des
ratios de patients par soignants dans
des services très spécifiques tels que
le bloc opératoire la réanimation ou
encore la dialyse instaurer des ratios à
chaque spécif spécialité pardon et
activités de soins permettrait une
amélioration des conditions de travail
et contribueraient à un peu plus
d'attractivité pour les personnels ce
serait également la garantie d'une
meilleure prise en charge des patients
la politique de réduction des dépenses
de santé et non recrutement de
personnels hospitaliers à mécaniquement
entraîné une augmentation du nombre de
patients sous leur responsabilité on le
sait l'une des causes majeures des
difficultés de recrutement et de la
fuite de personnels soignants en
particulier infirmiers est plus encore
que la faiblesse des salaires
l'augmentation de la charge de travail
due au manque d'effectif cette question
est d'autant plus importante qu'une
étude parue dans la revue scientifique
de l'ancêtre a démontré qu'en améliorant
le ratio soignant patients ont diminuait
la mortalité les réadmissions et la
durée de séjour l'idée donc force
séduisante malheureusement mes chers
collègues cette PPL ne présente pas que
des avantages en effet dans le contexte
actuel de pénurie cette proposition
risque plutôt de produire des effets
pervers non désirés sans recrutement
supplémentaire et à moyen constant
mettre en place des seuils minimum
induits forcément de prendre des
effectifs dans tel service pour
renforcer telle autre service autrement
dit déshabiller Pierre Paul nous avons
été alertés par des soignantes et des
soignants qui s'inquiètent d'une
possible concurrence entre les services
pour obtenir des ratios plus importants
en quelque sorte de voir s'ouvrir une
guerre entre chef de service en l'état
actuel des choses se dispositif peut
donc contribuer à accélérer la fermeture
de lit voir remettre en cause les 35
heures c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous estimons que l'instauration des
ratios soignants soignés doit aller de
pair avec une hausse massive de moyens
alloués à l'hôpital madame la ministre
vous vous êtes bien gardé de vous
engager sur ce terrain vous avez
effectivement fait l'éloge des
personnels dit qu'il fallait de
meilleures conditions de travail mais
actuellement le gouvernement n’entend
pas les revendications des soignants et
n'y répond pas dans une tribune au Monde
la sociologue Dominique Méda estimait
que la mise en place de tel ratio
nécessiterait l'embauche de 100 000
infirmières et infirmiers
supplémentaires pour un coup de 5
milliards d'euros madame la ministre la
balle est dans votre camp
tout en reconnaissant les contraintes
imposées au PPL nous recrêtons donc que
la proposition de loi ne cible pas les
sources de financement comme par exemple
la suppression des 75 milliards d'euros
d'exonération de cotisations sociales
enfin nous regrettons le choix de ne pas
associer les organisations syndicales à
la définition des besoins afin de fixer
ces ratios aux côtés de la Haute
Autorité de Santé et de la commission
médicale d'établissements par conséquent
la proposition de loi du groupe
socialiste on nous partageons l'objectif
s'arrête en quelque sorte au milieu du
gué en prenant le risque d'accompagner
les politiques de réduction des lits
raison pour laquelle le groupe crco
s'absiendra mais je trouve que c'est un
appel et c'est un appel que le
gouvernement doit encore entendre donc
le débat et le bienvenu aujourd'hui
merci chers collègues dernier orateur
inscrit Monsieur Laurent Burgoa pour le
groupe des Républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues personne
ne peut ignorer le profond malaise qui
touche le monde médical en témoigne la
crise de vocation qu'il traverse c'est
le même qui frappe également le corps
enseignant on ne choisit pas cette voie
professionnelle par hasard et c'est
heureux oui il s'agit bien là d'une
vocation mais cette vocation ne va pas
devenir un véritable sacerdoce
aujourd'hui l'enjeu est de s'assurer que
nos hôpitaux puissent se disposer de
ressources suffisantes afin de garantir
une qualité de soins optimale et de bien
meilleure condition de travail aux
soignants en effet ces dernières années
les hospitalisations conventionnelles
ont progressivement été remplacés par
des prises en charge ambulatoire de fait
les patients désormais hospitalisées
nécessitent quant à eux plus de temps
car leurs soins sont plus complexes et
les pathologies plus lourdes il s'agit
alors adopter les effectifs à cette
évolution et je tiens à remercier
personnellement le président de la CMU
du CHU de Nîmes pour m'avoir sensibilisé
à cet enjeu si des ratios sont déjà
fixés par décrire son mentionné dans le
corps de santé publique notamment
réanimation ou unité de soins intensifs
dans la plupart des autres services il
n'y a pas de règle en bonne et due forme
qui fixe un nombre de soignants par
patiable il convenait de clarifier les
choses et de préciser l'articulation des
ratiosexistant dit de sécurité avec ses
nouveaux ratios de qualité et non moins
important puisqu'à
découle une plus grande sécurité pour
les patients
la définition de ces nouveaux ratios
serait confiée à la Haute Autorité de
santé qui le fera par spécialité et par
activité de soins hospitalier et ce afin
de pouvoir répondre le plus précisément
possible aux différents besoins il était
important pour nous de valoriser une
approche de terrain aux prises avec les
réalités des établissements à la lecture
de la proposition de loi de notre
collègue Bernard jaumier nous avons
veillé à ne pas entrer davantage le mode
fonctionnement des hôpitaux et je pense
ici aux petites structures dont vous le
savez l'intérêt est grand dans nos
territoires en commission des affaires
sociales je tiens à remercier tant le
travail de la présente la commission que
demande le rapporteur nous avons nous
leur avons garanti une capacité
d'adaptation en fonction des différentes
spécialités et spécificités locales
parfois tout simplement lié à des
contraintes architecturales pression
tout de même que ces adaptations devront
avoir l'approbation des commissions de
médicales d'établissements et des
commissions des soins infirmiers la mise
à jour de ces ratios est d'ores déjà
prévu tous les cinq ans et une procédure
de signalement à l'agence régionale de
santé est prévue et ce en cas
d'incapacité prolongée de trois jours
afin de permettre une connaissance plus
fine de la situation de nos hôpitaux à
l'issue de travail en commission nous
avons ainsi considéré que cet équilibre
cher à notre institution avait été
trouvé et répandait aux préconisations
de nos précédents rapports
issu d'une commission d'enquête sur les
hôpitaux aujourd'hui en France et en
2023 il regretta avec le délit puisse
être fermé faute de personnel nous ne
pouvons l'accepter et si la mise en
place d'un ratio soignant patient offrir
un dédiablement de meilleure condition
de travail encore faut-il que ces
métiers deviennent plus attractifs en
les revalorisant sans cela je le crains
ces emplois resteront non pourvu et ces
nouveaux ratios intenables d'où la
progressivité voulue dans la mise en
oeuvre cette proposition de loi
rappelons que des effectifs suffisants
c'est permettre de remplacer plus
facilement les absences ou encore de
favoriser la formation en permettant
bien meilleur encadrement des plus
jeunes c'est ainsi cela l'intérêt de
cette proposition de loi et c'est la
raison pour laquelle mon groupe la
votera enfin et pour conclure comme
certaines concitoyens qui à l'issue
d'une hospitalisation se trouve très
admiratif et reconnaissant envers les
soignants l'état souvent en pleine crise
sanitaire déclare beaucoup d'amour aux
soignants mais ces belles déclarations
sont très peu suivies des faits alors
madame la ministre à l'approche de la
Saint-Valentin permettez-moi de vous
rappeler qu'en politique comme un amour
il n'y a que les actes qui comptent je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur Burgoa la discussion
générale est close nous passons à la
discussion du texte de la commission
madame la Présidente
attendez j'ai encore rien dit monsieur
jaubier vous voulez pas intervenir avant
le jour la discussion
merci monsieur le Président comme il n'y
a pas d'amendement sur ce texte je vais
expliquer en effet comment nous avons
travaillé en commission je voulais
remercier Bernard jaumier de cette
proposition qui correspond en effet une
des préconisations du rapport de la
commission d'enquête formulée dans des
termes un peu différents et je partage
Madame le Ministre ce n'est pas la
solution miracle ça c'est vrai mais il
faut beaucoup de leviers pour arriver à
résoudre le malaise de l'hôpital
celui-ci en fait partie la crainte que
nous avions eu au départ au niveau de
notre groupe c'était en effet de dire
mais comme imposé des ratios alors qu'on
est en pleine pénurie c'est ce pourquoi
je remercie la rapporteur et l'auteur
Bernard joli d'avoir tenu compte de ses
remarques d'abord d'avoir fait en effet
des une modulation selon les
établissements et selon les services
modulation selon de capacités ou le
sécurité ou le qualité ou le sécuritaire
mais surtout d'avoir donné un délai
suffisamment long alors madame le
ministre vous nous avez dit que vous
alliez faire plein de choses parce c'est
formidable parce qu'en 2027 les ratios
ne poseront aucun problème à ce
moment-là puisqu'il y aura tellement de
soignants qui seront restés à l'hôpital
ou revenus à l'hôpital qu'on aura
vraiment à ce moment-là une fourchette
qui sera indicative mais vraiment je
vous invite à voter ce texte qui est
certes une petite une petite solution
par rapport au mal-être qui est
croissant les présidents CM1 Laurent
Burgo elle a dit mais le président de la
Conférence des des CM1 Rémi Salomon de
Necker nous l'a dit aussi ils attendent
ce texte les soignants l'attendent donc
nous donnons un signal mais c'est aussi
un aiguillon pour que le gouvernement
poursuive en ce sens de façon à avoir
des soignants qui ne courent plus dans
tous les sens qui ne quittent plus
l'hôpital qui n'arrive plus stresser à
l'hôpital une meilleure qualité des
soins pour des patients de plus en plus
lourds et de plus plus chronique ou
polypathologique dont je vous invite à
vous teste merci madame la Présidente
alors puisque il y a plusieurs demandes
de parole je précise d'abord que nous
sommes saisis d'une demande de scrutin
public sur ce texte par le groupe
socialiste en conséquence je vous
demande de vous y préparer et je donne
la parole pour explication de vote à
Monsieur Chaumier
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
remercier les orateurs des différents
groupes qui
ont porté un message c'est le premier
que je crois qu'il fait consensus c'est
que nous devons écouter la demande
unanime des soignants et je salue celles
et ceux qui sont aujourd'hui en tribune
et nous écoutent parce qu'ils sont
unanimes effectivement on l'a constaté
lors des auditions à demander ce
dispositif et puis je veux saluer aussi
les différents groupes et ceux de la
majorité sénatale et en particulier la
présence de la commission avec
lesquelles il y a eu un vrai dialogue
pour que cette proposition pour
reprendre les mots du ministre François
Braun que cité Laurence Rossignol ne
soit ni brutal ni uniforme c'était la
demande du ministre et nous y avons
répondu la rapporteur et l'apprenant de
la Commission ont démontré que ce texte
n'était ni brutal deux ans pour établir
les référentiels deux ans de plus pour
les appliquer et des formes puisque il
se traduiront c'est clair dans le texte
par des fourchettes au niveau des
établissements et en fonction de leur
caractéristiques et des spécialités
alors je regrette madame la ministre que
vous en restiez à une position fermée le
parlementarisme et cette enceinte
particulièrement c'est d'accepter la
discussion et quand il y ait répondu de
ne pas camper sur la même déclaration de
principe ce ne doit être ni brutale
uniforme convenons tous qu'il n'y a pas
une mesure qui seule répondra à la
difficulté de nos hôpitaux mais
convenons que celle-ci est massivement
réclamé par les soignants et que fermer
la porte à cette disposition qui a fait
ses preuves dans beaucoup d'autres pays
c'est se priver d'une réponse réelle et
à l'heure où je vous parle
malheureusement les soignants continuent
à quitter nos hôpitaux il faut inverser
ce mouvement je remercie
merci la parole est à Madame Jourda
pas par eux madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales mais
également par notre collègue Bernard
jaumier sur les difficultés du monde
soignant sur la pénurie sur les
solutions qui peuvent être trouvées pour
y faire face et je voudrais interroger
madame la ministre sur une loi qui est
bien connue mais pas appliquée qui
s'appelle la loi Rist et qui a plafonné
la rémunération des intérimaires dans le
système hospitalier public cette loi n'a
pas été mise en oeuvre elle devait
l'être avant les élections ça explique
peut-être pourquoi elle n'a pas été mise
en œuvre si elle est mise en oeuvre elle
va vraisemblablement
déstabiliser un ensemble de services
médicaux qui ont un recours massif à
l'intérim et c'est pourquoi si elle doit
être mise en oeuvre elle doit l'être de
façon uniforme avec un certain courage
en prévenant les élus des difficultés
qui pourraient se passer et en aussi
s'organisant avec les ARS pour pouvoir
faire face à l'aide à déstabilisation de
tous ces services médicaux qui ont
beaucoup recours à l'intérim alors ma
question est la suivante
une date est-elle fixée pour appliquer
ce texte et nous laissera-t-elle le
temps de nous organiser sur les
territoires pour mettre en oeuvre encore
une fois cette mesure qui peut avoir de
graves répercussions sur nos hôpitaux je
remercie Madame et si elle veut bien me
répondre merci la parole de Madame Grey
merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre vous ne pouvez pas
d'un côté nous dire qu'on ferme les lits
par manque de soignants alors qu'il crie
toujours et depuis longtemps haut et
fort de leur mal-être et si aujourd'hui
il manque des soignants dans nos
services publics c'est aussi parce
qu'ils partent dans le privé où ils
partent également à l'étranger comme
dans le Nord en Belgique
alors il parle de leur mal-être on le
connaît leur mal-être c'est parce que
comme nous l'ont dit mais tous mes
collègues aujourd'hui ils ont des
agendas surchargés il y en a ils sont
rappelés chez eux pendant leurs vacances
ils n'ont pas de
d'agenda fixe il faut il faut le savoir
quand même ils ont appris un métier où
ils devaient écouter les personnes aider
au plus près les patients aujourd'hui
ils ne sont plus en capacité de passer
du temps avec les patients parce qu'ils
n'ont plus le temps de rien ils disent
eux-mêmes qui mettent en danger la vie
des patients d'ailleurs il y a l'étude
de 2016 de la Haute Autorité de santé
qui le relève plus la charge de travail
est élevée plus les impacts sont
négatifs sur les patients il y a un
risque d'erreur de raisonnement risque
de qualité de service donc depuis
longtemps on le dit on le crie haut et
fort la charge de travail est trop
élevée alors c'est des embauches qu'il
faut madame la madame ministre ici il y
a pas longtemps on a dit bah c'est pas
grave on va au niveau des services
publics on va faire le relais sur les
médecins traitants sauf que les médecins
traitant eux-mêmes n'en peuvent plus
c'est pour ça qu'ils se rassemblent et
qui manifeste donc Madame la Ministre on
fait un appel il faut embaucher c'est la
seule solution
merci
il n'y a pas d'autres demandes de parole
oui
allez-y madame merci
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
présente de la commission madame la
ministre lorsque nous avons travaillé au
sein de la mission d'enquête sur
l'hôpital le titre avait été sortir
l'hôpital des urgences mais nous avions
aussi hésité avec un titre qui disait
l'hôpital en ALD l'hôpital en affection
longue durée donc c'est vrai que nous
avons toujours bien posé les diagnostics
nous avons pris des photographies nous
avons fait des constatations mais à
chaque fois nous butions sur quelle
solution proposée donc je voudrais
vraiment féliciter notre confrère
d'avoir proposé cette solution qui est
un peu innovante et que vraiment je la
contrainte suscitant l'imagination je
voudrais vous féliciter d'avoir pensé à
cela pour rebondir sur ce que disait
notre autre collègue nous souffrons
aussi d'une médecine extrêmement
administrative maintenant si vous allez
dans les couloirs de l'hôpital autrefois
on beaucoup de chariots avec des
médicaments maintenant vous voyez des
gens avec des dossiers sous le bras qui
filent à une réunion pour aller encore à
une autre réunion de concertation et
pouvoir comment on va s'organiser
s'organiser en faisant encore une autre
organisation derrière et une autre
réunion donc effectivement dans ce titre
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est le
mot soignant notre métier c'est le
diagnostic et c'est le soin c'est ça que
nous devons faire c'est prendre soin de
nos patients c'est à dire mes chers
collègues de vous tous qui est des
passions en devenir
merci d'autres demandes
si ce qui souhaite prendre la parole
vous pouvez le faire d'un coup plutôt
coucou par coup ce serait plus facile
merci allez-y chers collègues
je comprends tout à fait monsieur le
président
monsieur je voulais m'associer
aux félicitations de la proposition qui
est faite au travers de ce texte d'abord
pour dire que la méthode des quotas
c'est une méthode qui est utilisée
depuis fort longtemps par
l'administration sanitaire pour
supprimer des lits et dire qu'avec ton
lit on supprime tant de pose
d'infirmiers et temps de pose des
soignants par exemple dans les hôpitaux
donc il peut pas y avoir des quotas
utiles c'est-à-dire à la bonne gestion à
dépenser moins parce que c'est ça la
bonne gestion depuis des années des
années quand on parle de bonheur
administration sanitaire et puis des
côtés qui seraient des quotas auprès du
patient de temps libérer de des
soignants auprès des patients et bien
moi je pense que ce texte de loi il a
cette proposition elle a le mérite de
remettre j'allais dire le soir au milieu
de l'hôpital et de dire que le plus bel
hôpital de la terre ne sera rien s'il y
a pas la qualité des soignants qui sont
dedans et on est en estimant un nombre
suffisant qui puisse passer suffisante
auprès des patients on mettra peut-être
un petit peu d'humain donc ce soin qui
est bien mal en point depuis pas mal
d'années
merci bien s'il n'y a plus de demandes
assis alors Monsieur Boyer
un panneau monsieur le président madame
la ministre je veux juste rendre hommage
à la PPL de notre collègue geomier je
visitais vendredi l'établissement Paul
Brousse de la PHP qui est dans ma
circonscription et je demandais au chef
de service au soignants que j'ai
rencontré finalement qu'est-ce que vous
attendez aujourd'hui des parlementaires
et de chefs de service m'ont dit votez
la PPL Chaumier voilà au fond c'est un
hommage et surtout une expression de
l'attente qu'ils ont d'avoir les moyens
nécessaires à l'exercice de leur mission
dans les façons acceptable donc je
respecterai c'était déjà mon choix au
préalable mais évidemment je respecterai
leur injonction
madame Humbert mais s'il y a vraiment
d'autres demandes de parole maintenant
voilà donc il y a plus que Madame
Humbert on est bien d'accord madame
Humbert merci monsieur le Président de
votre générosité madame madame la
ministre madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur non ça a été dit
effectivement cette proposition loi est
issue des travaux de la mission
d'information souhaitée par notre groupe
et dans Catherine des roches étaient
rapporteur et dont Bernard jaumier était
était le président et je tiens à saluer
le travail qui avait été fait alors
c'est quoi l'essentiel c'est quoi
l'essentiel à un moment de l'hôpital n'a
jamais été aussi fragile à un moment où
après trois années de pandémie des
professionnels de santé sont épuisés à
un moment nous n'avons jamais autant
parlé d'attractivité des métiers et pas
seulement dans le domaine de la santé
alors la présente Catherine de roche la
rappeler le professeur émi Salomon
président de la CM2 de l'AP-HP
a dit que c'était un signal nécessaire à
destination des soignants
l'enjeu évidemment est de stopper et de
stopper le départ des soignants de
l'hôpital de stopper la fermeture de lit
faute de soignants et y compris dans les
services de soins palliatif hier nous
faisions une audition avec Michel
Meunier et Catherine bouffentinoza ou
nous recevions une table ronde
d'associations et qu'est-ce qui nous
était dit c'est que même dans les
services de soins palliatifs des lits
sont fermés vous imaginez bien le drame
à la fois évidemment pour les patients
et pour les familles donc c'est cette
situation dont nous que nous ne
supportons plus moi je remercie la
rapporteur comme l'a dit Catherine de
roche d'avoir étalé dans le temps
l'application de cette proposition de
loi parce qu'elle est plus crédible et
je remercie le gouvernement de l'écoute
et du travail qui sera fait pour que
cela soit possible et qu'on ait plus
différemer ce qui est insupportable pour
tous les patients et pour tous les
soignants je vous remercie
merci alors pour boucler le tour la
parole est à madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président pour
répondre à la question posée sur la mise
en application de la ppliste sur
l'intérim la loi sera mise en
application le 3 avril 2013 2013 2023
2023 2023 donc le 3 avril 2023
et le travail en amont a été fait avec
les ARS et les directeurs de peytho le
travail préparatoire est en train de se
faire un consigne a été donné en ce sens
aux ARS et bien sûr
des facto avec les élus derrière je le
redis
madame Imbert vous venez de vous venez
de le dire
il est insupportable que l'héli ferme
nous le savons tous et pourquoi les lits
ferme les différents parce qu'il n'y a
plus de personnels soignants
c'est pas parce que c'est pas parce que
les ratios sont impliqués que les
personnels reviendront nous sommes nous
intimement convaincus que il faut comme
ça a été dit nous souhaitons tous
prendre soin des patients prendre soin
des patients c'est prendre soin des
patients avec le bon nombre de
personnels au bon endroit au pied du lit
du patient et des personnels qui sont
formés c'est bien l'enjeu important que
nous devons faire et permettre aux
soignants de revenir travailler à
l'hôpital c'est tout l'enjeu en termes
de qualité de vie au travail c'est la
flexibilité à l'échelle du service c'est
la qualité de vie au travail c'est
l'autonomie de la liberté et la
confiance que nous devons au personnel
soignants au pied de nos patients donc
nous serons bien sûr nous partageons la
philosophie qui était celle et je salue
le travail mené par la commission madame
la Présidente nous partageons la
philosophie la réponse apportée n'est
pas tout à fait la même
merci madame la ministre je vais mettre
voix l'article unique constituant
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi au
scrutin public le scrutin est ouvert
ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin 117 compte
tenu de l'ensemble des délégations de
vote accordée par les sénateurs
politiques et notifiés à la présidence
nombre de votants 336 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 272 pour l'adoption
256 contre 16 le Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
je suspends la séance sur site le temps
du changement d'équipe